Let's go over the problem again.
We want to build an application with a list of cats, and when you
click on the cat in the list, they will display in the cat viewing area here.
And what's more, the number for
the number of clicks should always reflect the number of the current cat.
We're going to go through this right now and
figure out what should belong to the model, the view or views, and the octopus.
First, let's identify the model and the view portions.
Of the following things, choose whether they belong in the model or the view.
The clickable list of cats here, the current cat display, and
the array of cat objects which is driving all of this.